[Musique]
impossible de résister plus longtemps
passant automobilistes rien ni personne
ne peut arrêter andré il lui faut à nu
le jour la nuit n'importe quand
n'importe où joséphine fait le guet et
andré écrit son nom sur les mots dans la
rue chez lui andres est un maniaque de
la bombe toujours à portée de la main
prêt à servir la petite maison où il
habite à paris avec sa mère va être
détruite
il s'amuse à lui donner des couleurs
depuis qu'il tags et qui enfin andré
délaisse un peu le lycée dans un an il
doit passer le bac mais son école c'est
le tag dans la rue je tape quand j'ai
créé mon nom plus d'endroits possibles
le plus gros possible dans les endroits
les plus dangereux et c'est un jeu
plutôt avec la police avec eux avec la
cité c'est un peu une auto pub ce fut ma
propre publicité à j'écris mon non plus
n'ont plus d'endroit posthume
les gens dans le milieu je suis quoi
force de voir mon nom se rappelle de moi
ces pages voit pas mais je tacle paris
couvert de tags paris massacre est
retourné cartonné comme disent les
tagueurs vous croyez les jeunes gaver de
télé abruti par le top 50
et les voilà qui prennent les armes
bombe et marqueurs en vente partout
le mode d'emploi est simple d'abord se
trouver un surnom plus un lettrage et
enfin prendre d'assaut les trains et les
murs de paris tous les tagueurs le
disent pas facile de lâcher la bombe
quand on a pris goût aux tags ainsi
bandeau ils taguent sans relâche depuis
huit ans pour la ratp c'est l'ennemi
public numéro un
fils de bonne famille il est devenu
voyous juste par amour des cinq lettres
de son nom
[Musique]
bandy39 préfère aujourd'hui rester dans
l'ombre
voilà l'important c'est qu'on va
rebondir pas moi ma faute il peut se
passer n'importe quoi je continuerai
dans la mesure où genre je parle au
téléphone passés haut la main je
commence à massacrer sur des feuilles de
papier par tous était dicté ainsi on est
obligé de décrire ça même pas écrire
pour communiquer c'est écrire pour le
plaisir d'écrire intégralité c'est
redécouvrir le plaisir d'écrire seront
fondard mais bon une fois qu'on commence
et finit qua non c'est plus possible
d'arrêter
non c'est du turc semih roi mince et moi
vous allez vous quelques minutes
suffisent pour 93 ntm dans l'entrepôt
désert de la sncf ils repeignent le rer
à leurs couleurs publicité sauvage
illégal codé le seul moyen qu'ils ont
trouvé pour faire parler d'eux
déjà très remarqué 93 tél il faut que 5
à trois points ça partout qui perd tels
que quac voilà c'est ça le style quoi il
faut qu'on dit qu'on joue et à c'est ça
le goût du risque
le talent c'est une signature parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps de faire un grave
déjà y'a pas assez mûr on nous
permettent pour faire un graphe quoi
personne vedrin qu'on fasse un graphe en
pleine rue alors pourvu qu'on n'a pas le
temps on pose carrément intacte pour une
signature est plutôt posé plus tu es
connu quoi bon aliment on va vous
épargner quelques vocabulaire le flop
ces deux lettres flop des boules c'est
plutôt rond un peu gros il ya le bois de
clamser les lettres carrées quoi c'est
dû céder cucquois et on coupe de dans
les combles et lettres kong désert pour
dessiner vite faire comme ça il faut
s'entraîner je suis blanc il est noir la
différence ne se voit que dans les yeux
des bâtards trop tard différences
ethniques alliance de culture voilà la
raison de notre progression c'est sûr
j'ai l'esprit car voyant et les yeux
bien ouverts qu'à jasmin c'est super
mais qu' avoir inspecté à 80 à 100 tous
les soi disant prophète les propagateurs
adulateurs d'une race par petr c'est
clair et net
la démonstration est faite pour cent
pour le pen aux élections est une des
pets en fait ça dans ta face quelle que
soit ta race blanc et noir noir et jaune
sont les rouges
je m'adresse à la jeunesse elle qui se
dresse sans cesse sans peur ni crainte
pas 193 cm c'est au 6e jeu les 93 ntm
pas de barrière entre les couleurs les
races ils ont grandi ensemble dans les
mêmes sites et de saint denis
ils ont 18 20 ans certains travaillent
beaucoup galère chez eux et pas de
frontières entre le tag le rap la danse
ou le graffiti un seul mot d'ordre bouge
derrière le tag un mode de vie un
mouvement métis et le hip hop
les etats-unis ont donné le signal saint
denis et toute la banlieue est entré
dans la danse à la fac de saint denis le
rap et le mouvement sont déjà étudiés en
cours et certains prépare une thèse sur
le sujet quand tu grandis que tout le
temps de parler des gaulois des gaulois
des gaulois comprendre des photos de
gaulois blond aux yeux bleus
tu dis évidemment moi je ressemble pas
du tout un gaulois dont tu t'y bombard
alors que je sache
douch mis un petit peu puis ce mouvement
là c'est ce que ça permet aussi c'est à
dire que tous les gens qui se posent
plus ou moins cette question ou qui sont
un petit peu exclus ou plus ou moins
quoi qui font de parano aussi des fois
ces gens là bas ils se réunissent tous
ces pays forment une espèce de ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas avant d'une culture quoi
la culture si tu veux comme nos ancêtres
auraient pu la voir mais sur le bitume
c'est à dire qu'on est dans le béton bas
autant faire avec
enfin sur bancs de thon parallèlement je
te dis moi quelle que soit ta couleur
quelle que soit ta nature aucune race
mais supérieure car il n'a pas de
couleur pour être prêt car d'honneur à 6
sur le prix jugé car noir ou blanc
rapaces et une au fond car je me nourris
de 93 ntm c'est encore lui mode tout il
s'est fait la main sur les murs les
métros de paris et de londres
aujourd'hui il pas l'entrée la fac de
saint denis et personne ne veut manquer
ça tous disent de lui qu'il s'est donné
une âme au mieux dans les toiles des
gens et des gardes chez eux les murs
s'asseoir et c'est pas genre si tu as un
truc à dire
de valable c'est papa essaie de le
mettre sur un surveillant comme ça plus
les gens vont voir voici dans dans la
rue celle de dans la communauté quoi
créer un peu de un discours entre c'est
pas genre de gens qui ne quitte jamais
ses parents dans dans la rue 6-3 devant
devant un mur c'est assez nouveau ils
ont des trucs à se demander quoi que
j'en des délais question à se poser dans
les nôtres en demeurant
mtm ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire nique ta mère maintenant
c'est la seule façon qu'on a trouvé de
se faire remarquer et en plus je veux
dire c'est une expression qu'on utilise
tous les jours qui
tu peux être l'équivalent de zut ou
merde oui a quand même des gens qui le
prennent au premier degré c'est
regrettable
on n'a qu'une vie quoi on s'amuse donc
en même temps voilà quoi on s'amuse
productive manquant en étant productif
au montage on s'amuse tout en étant
feront des petits fait clair t'as le
toucher l'état maire d'oka l'endroit
comme à l'envers c'est clair j'ai le
tout chimique la mer sur les côtés comme
par derrière c'est clair j'ai le touche
il est amer et donc à l'endroit comme à
l'envers sur les côtés comme par
derrière c'est clair j'ai le plus jeune
est amer au départ du red star
aujourd'hui les amendes pleuvent sur les
tagueurs prise en flagrant délit mais
rien n'y fait nettoyés et recouvert les
tags et les graffitis pousse toujours
que nombreux dans la ville à
déchiffrable illisible insupportable
pour beaucoup ça n'est pour eux qu'une
première étape
la seule partie visible d'un mouvement
plus vaste hall r oui les enfants des
banlieues et du métro veulent prendre
leur revanche
ils ont grandi ensemble dans les écoles
d'art parfois des écoles tous les
conservatoires contre tous ils ont
inventé leur propre style leur propre
musique leur propre danse est louche au
même rythme dans toutes les grandes
villes de la planète avec un de
mouvements le move comme ils disent est
en marche et ça n'a rien à voir avec une
mode c'est juste une question de survie
[Musique]